aren't free games the best if you're a
PlayStation Plus member you're already
nodding your head vigorously while
drooling at the thought of new game
presumably while strapped on a bib as I
run down february's release schedules
the big game this month lands on the
PlayStation 4 outlast is and I quote
from a very smelly man pooping your
pants terrifying disgusting you betcha
but i'm not going to shield you from the
truth if you've ever wanted to visit a
haunted insane asylum now's your chance
you creepy weirdo you staying on the
horror theme metro last light is going
to be zero cents on the playstation
3gamespot zone kevin van noord
absolutely adored this mutant hunting
shooter placing it atop his game of the
year list yeah it's that good you don't
have to shell out 1 buffalo nickel to
play it wow that's great hey day 2 is
also coming to the PlayStation 3 it's a
high scam that inevitably goes badly
just like Dog Day Afternoon or every
other heist movie oh and once you get
past the clown masks it's darn fun not
so fun remember me but it is a
futuristic game starting a strong female
protagonist so it's not all bad Plus neo
Paris that's totally a place and don't
forget about the Vita street fighter
cross tekken may not have overthrown
street fighter 4 in the fighting game
community but you can have Zangief
fighting a bear or team up with one it's
your choice
last and certainly least is modnation
racers road trip a far cry from the last
free Vita racing game sonic & all-stars
racing transformed but it's still a free
video game so you can't complain too
much hope you enjoy this month's
election and if not just replaced belong
key you just go blows yeah I'll blow
these dudes don't worry about yeah I
would like you to get in there and they
won't hold still it's hard to blow him
when it keeps moving around